biomimicry is about copying nature's
best ideas the ocean is a great place to
look for brilliant solutions to some of
the challenges we face on land as well
as in the sea one of the more exciting
innovations is the use of sharkskin
patterns on hospital surfaces in
hospitals right now superbugs are
forming because we use so many
antibiotics we need a new way to deal
with bacteria without killing them
scientists were very curious about the
Galapagos shark it's a slow-moving
basking shark and so they expected to
find a lot of bacteria on its surface
and yet there were no bacteria what
actually was happening was they had nano
ridges arm that were uncomfortable for
bacteria to land on a company called
sharklet has mimicked this surface
structure to create thin films that you
can put on door handles railings and
other hospital services and bacteria
just simply do not like to land there so
here you have a whole new way of dealing
with bacteria repelling them rather than
killing them in the US there's a hundred
thousand hospital-acquired infections
every year to be able to prevent those
by something as simple as a shape is a
real breakthrough to learn more about
biomimicry subscribe to the wired
Channel